we are presenting this as a conversation
so I will be asking Arlen about her own
story and strategies and then we'll open
the floor up for questions so I'll be
doing Q&A for about 40 minutes and then
we'll open it up for the rest of the
class to jump in so Arlen I'd like to
start with the founders journey there is
there is I would say oftentimes two
narratives that get told about founders
there is a narrative about founders as
vision holders where you have a founder
who can see into the future more clearly
than anybody else and uses that vision
to trumpet the resources they need think
about Elon Musk saying I want to go to
Mars and we're all going to get there
and then there's another narrative that
says that actually entrepreneurship is
not about knowing the end but it's all
about managing the process and that the
end can be far bigger than you ever even
expected and the great founders are ones
that can manage the risks along the way
and there are process driven
methodologies the design school at
Stanford's probably the most famous year
with the d.school methodology and so I
want to start out with this question did
you know when you were a child that you
wanted to be a venture capitalist did
you have the vision of being a venture
capitalist when you were younger no when
I was younger I shaved one of my
eyebrows off when I that tells you
something yeah yes that's the story and
and I had to pencil my mom had to pencil
it in for weeks with her eyeliner so no
I was a and did you know what venture
capital was no I didn't know until my
30s what venture capital really was I
heard the term and in the in the ether
but I did not know what it was I also
didn't care and it was and it was my
early 30s that I started to understand
what venture capital was and so when I
was a child since I was very little
though I was definitely a founder and so
I feel like this says this is definitely
full circle because you had that spirit
inside of you what and so can you just i
I don't want to summarize your whole
life up but can you then mark the
salient moments in your life and paint
the picture for what it was like as a
what you were like as a child and then
how you went from that to being the
venture capital uh the the starter and
founder of a venture capital fund today
I'd love to can I get a little
understanding though of who has heard of
backstage capital just so I can
understand okay great I was an adorable
child as you can probably imagine I was
very precocious as they say I was very
once my mother told me it was okay to
speak up I spoke up as soon as I only
had to learn that lesson once so I asked
a lot of questions when I was a child I
was also very tall and what we like to
call big bonded as a child so I was kind
of a you know intimidating to some
including teachers for whatever reason
even though it was goofy and very good
student and I asked every question I
could it you know I remember back on the
fifth grade I think it was a fourth
grade they asked that question about if
a tree falls in the woods doesn't make
you know if snowing does it make a sound
if you know what hears it and I remember
still to this day I thought my answer
was it makes the vibration that cause a
sound and like the fourth grade you know
and I was thinking about that sort of
thing and I remember being a sort of the
dismissed when I said that by the
teacher because it was just like it
wasn't something that she was expecting
to hear from but I was at the same time
I was like obsessed with like the
lemonade stand type of things so I I had
a little candy shop going in the third
grade I also wore six watches and in the
third grade cuz I was a little odd but
it was because I was like totally odd
and it's gonna be a great first scene of
the Lifetime movie one day but it was
because I found out from an encyclopedia
which I could read very early I found
out that there are people in other parts
of the world who had it was a different
time for them and for some people it was
dark while it was light with where it
was with where I was and that blew my
mind and so from a very early age I felt
a deep connection to people from all
over the world even though I didn't
quite understand the scope of what that
really meant so everything from that
on I can trace back to Watson connection
and seeking it and also building it and
catalyzing it and you said that you
always knew that you were foundered what
I want to know is you know the class
that I teach is called the spirit of
entrepreneurship and part of that is
under trying to understand this
ineffable drive that certain people have
to break out from the pack
whereas others don't and there is one
school of thought that says that you're
just born that way and maybe that what's
the case that you always knew that you
are a founder and there's another school
of thought that says actually almost
just like the narrative of superheroes
who always have these mythologies where
they develop these strengths and
stressful situations that real skills
and real superhero strengths actually
get galvanized in times of stress not
pleasure if you agree with that what I'm
wondering is what would you say are your
superhero strengths and did those get
galvanized in times of stress or do you
feel like they were just intrinsic to
you I think it's all a mixture of all of
that because I think that I definitely
enjoyed it before it was something that
I thought I needed to do but I also
remember early on understanding what
money was and what lack of money was and
what it meant and that it made my mom
cry not having it and that if I can't
find a way to get it that would change
things or I thought it would and so it
was a little bit of both I do think it
was because it started kind of in a
third grade I think it was really
intrinsic I also think superpower wise I
think I call myself like the Simon
Cowell which is like probably a not a
good reference for this crowd because
you're you could all be my children I
think at this point I'm 39 yes you could
wow that's crazy
but I can I can I can see potential very
early and I can and I think I have good
taste and and people and things and and
I can see around corners a little bit
and you've always been a founder would
you say like even when you were a kid
you were doing odd oh yeah I was I had
my candy shop and then I had my my
paint-by-number I painted on the
sidewalks on the curb of people's houses
so the pizza delivery person could find
them easier at night and I did all this
from very early
and what's the difference though there's
a difference in you in a candy shop and
being an entrepreneur in that way and
then building a venture capital fund
from really I mean is there is there a
difference between a side hustle
have you seen ego as well and maybe
there's not but do you think there's a
difference between a side hustle and a
viable business that you can commit your
life to or do you view it is all the
same form of entrepreneurship I mean one
can become the other okay I think it's
very legitimate to start as a side
hustle and begin turn it into something
I do I interview people on my first
million podcast all the time who started
something that was away from what their
day job was they start on the weekend or
they started it as something that
started in their kitchen or something
and it went on to make millions of
dollars and and be there their life's
work so far so I think both yeah I just
have to say that you know there's that
we have many people in the entrepreneur
thought leader seminar who are founders
of startups and they talked about that
journey to be a founder of a start-up I
personally come up from a venture
capital background and I know how much
harder it is to actually start a fund
can you educate people on what the
difference is between being a founder of
a fund versus being a founder of a
start-up and why that is why I would
consider that what it why it's more
challenging in some ways it's like
riding a unicycle on fire under water on
the Sun so I've done both and I mean
definitely you know I haven't built like
I've built a lot of little companies and
a lot of little projects and things and
then I built this massive kind of
movement starter thingy with this fund
and firm but I have seen 6,000 plus
companies in the last five or so years
invested in 130 of them and I in a lot
of a lot of cases we are with them and
the trenches side by side and even as as
as you know I don't want it to be like
the oppression Olympics
it's like yours more difficult but I can
say even comparing it to anything I've
done in the past or anything that I
would do like if I wanted to have a
break I would start a company that I was
passionate about because this is raising
a fun is really difficult I think the
way that I did it and chose to do it and
put myself out there isn't on a whole
new level so I would even I would even
say raising a fund is harder than
raising like raising for a company or
starting a company but that you know can
debate me about that if you're a founder
and I would say raising it the way that
we have is more difficult than your than
your average fund yeah let me just
double emphasize that because I would
say you know if people PI don't realize
this but when you raise money for a
start-up you have to get maybe one
investor maybe a one institutional
investor maybe a handful of angel
investors but one investor can make all
the difference and then you're off when
you raise money for a fund you typically
need to get at least ten investors
because nobody wants to own more than a
certain percentage of that fund so it's
like hurting a ton of cats and many
people would say that you can't do that
unless you you know you work at a
venture fund for a while and so what I
think is just the the holy thing that
you've done is raise a fund from a
lateral a lateral move and and I want
people to really understand this so you
know the definition of entrepreneurship
that we often use this from this Harvard
professor Howard Stevenson who talks
about entrepreneurship as the pursuit of
opportunity without regard for resources
controlled and that usually we can talk
about that in this class but it comes
more in stark relief when you really
come from a place where you have no
advantages in that domain and I want
people just to understand the grit that
it takes to do what you did can you walk
us through how many emails you have to
send and how many meetings you had to
have and other hustles to get to your
first check in the fund and how big that
first check was yeah so approximately
three years of knows so nothing at least
half of that if not more without a
permanent residence and in a lot of
cases
just really not knowing where I was
gonna sleep that night and a lot of
cases not having having like one meal
understood like actually it's I'll break
for a second to tell you that I went to
a course here at Stanford in this same
hallway like around the corner for two
weeks that kind of was where I met my
first LP Susan and it was a lot of
million and Kimberly Susan chemically I
say her name every time um it was a lot
of millionaires in this course cuz it
was like a how do you spend your money
better sort of thing and I was the only
one that I know of who was like broke
broke and so I would they didn't no one
knew this in the class but I would like
figure out how to put together like a
dollar 19 or dollar nine one of the
taxes so I could go to Taco Bell down
the street when I got back to where I
was staying and have like my dinner and
that was 2015 so that was like just a
few months before I got my first check
from Susan so it had been months and
years of that and I probably I don't
know the exact number but I when I was
on I was featured on gimlets startup
podcast series last year and they
recorded me four months before it came
out and they had me just go back and do
all this crazy vetting of her you know
diligence on me for me to say did you
really do that thing that you said you
did and four months ago on tape so I'd
have to go find the proof the evidence
in an email which thankfully I still had
because I have these emails so I was
able to look and like just in searching
for a word or a phrase I was like oh my
god like I talked about how much I how
much out outreach I did but my goodness
seeing them just back I mean I'm talking
hundreds of emails but maybe more than
that maybe the thousands over those
three years and how many knows do you
think before your first yes hundreds
hundreds and how big was that first yes
after three years and hundreds of knows
and approximately fifty thousand dollars
fifty in in a world where which was
amazing and I will always be grateful to
Susan for that because no one was
anything but this is in a world where I
had to compete with people had millions
out the gate can you walk me through
what that's like - so you I can't fathom
this and I want to just make this really
clear for people so you would you're
going to these meetings you're pitching
these people you're you're going to the
Stanford class to hobnob with the
millionaires and you don't know AB now
that's a and thank you and and where are
you where where are you waking up where
are you going to sleep how are you
dealing with the bifurcation of that
world are you pretending you're one
thing and then or absolutely not okay so
can you walk us through just what it's
like okay so it's like it was different
at different times so I started out in
parallel in Texas near it what part of
Houston and parallel when I first
started learning about VC and and the
disparities in capital between white men
and everyone else getting capital from
venture capital I was in peril and I was
in an apartment with my mom I had my
bedroom I had a blow-up bed and I had a
whiteboard that I was teaching myself
about cap tables on and reading Brad
Feld books and we got kicked out of that
because we couldn't pay the rent so then
we moved into a Comfort Inn and we
shared a room and every night or every
morning we'd figure out how to pay for
the next for the next night and
sometimes we'd go down and talk to the
owner and he would see us coming and
he'd be like and we'd be like hey man
hey yeah can we get like a week just you
know and we just ended up I mean for
like two years it was the address to my
driver's license because I we lived
there and we just made our way and with
my mama go out and get a gig and I would
get in she's in her 60s at that time I
would go out and get a gig I was trying
to get a car so I could work for uber
because it was the early years of that
couldn't get a car all of that and then
couldn't afford that anymore move to
pflugerville in Austin north of Austin
because I want to be closer to two
startups if I couldn't be in Silicon
Valley oh and at least be closer in
Texas just startup world at that time
and it wasn't at that time so prevalent
in Houston and got a kind of a lifeline
in the form of a small personal loan
from Sam Altman which is a whole nother
story and that helped us have an Airbnb
for a few months and like because he
understood but well while I was at the
Airbnb is when I got the word that I was
gonna be able to come here for this 500
startups program that you all have and I
didn't have any money and it costs a lot
of money even though I was getting a
scholarship it cost a lot of money so
made my way here and I had about 10 days
worth of Airbnb and in fact there's a
guy here who had his own company that
like was venture funded and I was
staying at his place in East Palo Alto
and I couldn't pay him at the end of it
and like he let me like there's these
people that have kind of gone back to
and things because he let me stay for a
few days but I was in these classes so
to answer your question about what was I
portraying myself as I I was never
ashamed of any of this I was actually
proud but I was surviving but I wasn't
going to put my whole you know sad sack
story to anybody that wasn't important I
tried that a couple of times and I'm
like wait a minute that's that's not
really what this is about
because what this is about is getting
more funding to underrepresented
founders it's about me seeing a great
great deal flow it's about a fund that
needs to exist and all of this is gonna
be temporary and we'll get to business
the business out of it so I did end up
sleeping at the airport and I don't
recommend it and I'm not joking I say
that people start laughing but what I'm
saying is there have been people who
have started staying at the airport to
try to impress me and I find it really
insulting and painful when they do that
because I didn't do that for fun or
giggles and they're trying to do it so
I'm just really saying don't cross that
line and don't do that don't put
yourself in that position because I was
there because it was the safest place I
could be without any place to live yep
well let me shift now then to talk about
identity and the thesis for back-back
state back backstage back statement she
likes nextage yes so
you talk about how less than 10% of
venture capital dollars go to people of
color LGBTQ or women and and and that is
the focus of the fund can you is what
does the world not still appreciate or
understand about underestimated
minorities that you would like to shine
a light on I mean a lot so much we don't
have time for it here I mean it's I
always have to kind of laugh because I
mean look at this room look at the room
you can't tell me that the only people
in this room are the white only people
in this room we can start great
companies that are profitable are the
the few white guys that are here right
even the white guys in here I can't say
that doesn't make any sense right so
it's there's this still to this day
there's this whole thing of as soon as
you say DNI diversity inclusion
underrepresented even underestimated
which we've coined people start they
immediately go to that is either an HR
problem or that is a charity problem or
that is a down-and-out poor you problem
instead of that's your problem now
because that's your biggest competition
coming for you and coming for you
without any of this baggage of what they
think they're expected to be and so
you're seeing it now you're saying
that's there's a reason Delaine
the eSports CEO just raised about a
hundred million dollars for his company
out of nowhere you didn't see him coming
we did we saw we saw him years ago
there's a reason that these things are
happening because we don't sit around if
you're a woman you know this already you
know that you're a master multitasker
and sometimes you'll be sitting and I'm
talking to the ladies now right now
you'll be sitting with the guy and he'll
say something that he did and how
difficult it was and you'll just be like
I did that before noon before I even got
here you know what I mean and it's like
that so everybody in this room even
straight white men have something that
they're underestimated about because
everybody everybody no matter how good
of a person they are is prejudges so
when you walk into a room or you're in a
room and someone's judging you
like I'll give it a quick example
because I think it's important to think
about privileged in all cases so I can
have this whole conversation say all
this and I can say and white guys did
this and this and that and then we can
all get up to leave and I can notice
that one of the white men that I was
talking about is in a wheelchair
and I made the assumption that he had it
easier than I did because he's away
Europe so there there's it's it's
everywhere and I just think people are
still sleeping and that's better for me
make me even more wealthy faster I need
to wake up and then so then do you
espouse I think there's sort of two
schools of thought when it comes to
identity there was a school of thought
that talks about how difference is an
advantage and you should trumpet your
difference and it's also because you're
looking at the world differently and so
trumpet the differences and then there's
another school of thought that says no
what we really need to espouse is to
transcend differences or identities and
realize that it's really superficial how
do you reconcile those two or I mean I
don't necessarily agree when people like
I know sometimes it's coming from a good
place but if someone says I don't look
at color I don't see color well that's
that's like your privilege talking you
you get not to look at color but people
who are of color or black or however you
want to call it let Knicks or whatever
we have to think about color every day
of our lives if we're walking around in
this country and I mean today I was at
an event and I went to go get a little
snack at the hotel snack place and I was
like looking at it with my little Visa
card you know I'm gonna pay for these
expensive almonds because it can $6.99
and a nice little friendly Caucasian
lady just ran up to me where can I pay
for these and I'm like I don't know you
should ask someone who works here maybe
we should do that and she's just you
know work and it happens all the time
and I'm always mistaken for the help and
this and that so we have to see I think
you have to
I think it's disingenuous to say that
we're not different I think it's it's
just not realistic and it's not mature I
think we say yes we are different in
this way my difference everybody the
cool thing is that there's there
every single human being is different
than everyone else no matter what even
if you're twin so you use the strengths
of your differences and and talk about
it openly that's my opinion
now you shifted so you have this
headline fund that you're pursuing now
called be it's about damn time yes and
also the name of my book that you can
pre-order right now you can open up go
ahead and open up your phones it's prh
calm slash it's about damn time go ahead
and click that pre-order but there's the
founder here's the founder if you have
the means go for it
but you just try the the headliner fund
it's about damn time fund is
specifically focused on black women so
you decide to say get you decided to
narrow the focus down more can you
explain why focus just on black women
and how is that decision made sure can
yes
so we invest in women people of color
LGBTQ which is a lot a lot of people is
more than half the population even just
at women right and we invested in a
hundred of those and in that and that
thesis then I look at the the stats and
it said that women well there's - some
people say we get black women get point
two percent of all venture funding which
if you do the math last year 130 billion
dollars was deployed so we shared as
black women in startups shared the
equivalent of birds last round of
funding some people say it's even less
than that if and I looked at that and I
said and I also understood that for
every million dollars that a white man
raises a black woman raises twenty eight
thousand when she is able to raise right
not if you're doing apples to apples cuz
it would be you miniscule so I said
they're the only reason you could have a
problem with me starting a fund that
just puts her on level ground is if
you're afraid that she will beat you
when she gets there and so to me it was
just a it's one more part of the thesis
it's one more vertical just like we just
like if I had been
for three years and I realized you know
what
AI is where I'm gonna focus this next
fun that's the same way I look at it and
don't you think there's a power in focus
and yet simplicity even though because I
think some people would argue that those
same claims to differing degrees can be
made about the other communities that
you they can and there's nothing to say
that we won't do other funds but we're
starting there and how do you respond to
people to say that say that you know you
are responding to an injustice with an
injustice that there's your fund itself
is it would depend on how they're saying
it if they're saying it on Twitter in
their basement with their thumbs they
can they can go fly somewhere because
honestly it doesn't mean anything to me
if they're honestly if they honestly see
a problem with this and they're willing
to talk to me about it like a mature
person I'd love to have the conversation
when you have I don't know if we've
heard but I said point two percent is
the high version of the number that
black women get in venture funding and
we make up nearly 10% of the population
at 7 or 8 percent of translation doesn't
make any sense already that should be
what people are worried about and upset
about they should not be upset about
someone coming in and saying you know
what I'm just gonna slightly try to
change that to 0.1 percent you know so I
want to end on focusing on a little bit
around principle driven entrepreneurship
and then we'll open it up for clap for
Africa for questions but I I want to
sort of double click on two specific
scenarios to really dive deep into
understanding how to be a principled
driven founder and this is one of the
core new focuses for us TVP is thinking
about principle driven entrepreneurship
there was a situation where you were
offered a 250 K cheque as an investment
to backstage capital from Peter Thiel no
oh so it was someone associated with him
sorry he doesn't probably know that
exists okay
but that 250 K check is 25k Susan
Kimberlin checks that's that's 1025 K
checks that you could give to black
women um that would actually make them
make their businesses potentially
survive when they otherwise would fail
correct you said no to that - 50 K
cheque correct
can you walk through your principle
driven process on how you made that
decision
so it was it was it feels like a
lifetime ago
but it was in October of 2016 and what
happened was for a couple of months
someone had been talking to me about
this like closing out this fund the
first fund so our first one was ended up
being 1.2 million and I mean it was so
hard earned you know it was brick by
brick by brick and we needed that last
bit of it to close it out because we had
companies in queue that we had chosen
there's 2% of what we had seen so we
really needed it just to keep going -
and so this comes this person who was
very wealthy came in there people got in
touch with me and said you know we're
interested in doing this they want to be
anonymous publicly so you wouldn't say
who it was this this and that
so I knew who it was and the stuff
started happening with Trump get it you
know getting who's gonna be the nominee
and he was the nominee and he was gonna
do all this and then these tapes come
out of him saying things about grabbing
women and sexual assault him admitting
to that and the same kind of time period
Peter was a partner or like a visiting
partner at Y Combinator now I just told
you earlier that Sam Altman is a friend
of mine and helped me before that did
not stop the fact that I felt it was
wrong for Peter to still be there and
enjoy that that privilege of being there
so I called that out on Twitter I said
I'm no longer going to be sending
companies that way they I'm not stopping
them from going there not saying you're
bad if you go there I personally will
not continue to send the deal flow that
I have been helping YC with until he's
gone
that was just my personal decision and
when I said that out loud I became this
whole thing it was picked up on all of
these at all this press and Sam got in
touch with me and Michael got in touch
Amina does this whole thing and at the
same time I was like wait a minute I
know that this other person is so like
entrenched in that Peter teal world
let's just see what they're saying
online about it like it doesn't mean
that they're a bad person because
Sampson a bad person right there were
good friends let's just see what they're
saying and I go over to their social
media and there
just defending till I should say that
till I'm sorry I forgot to make the
connection he during that same time
announced or it was announced that he
put another million dollars behind Trump
now if let me tell you this if till had
run for president himself I like a
conservative or libertarian or
conservative ticket I wouldn't have
agreed with him for a moment but I would
have respected the hell out of him I
would I did not respect was him saying
you know what he's saying this about
people of color he's saying this about
likes very specifically about Mexican
people he's saying this about immigrants
he's saying this about women he's done
these things to women some of it he's
admitted to some of it he's been accused
of that's horrible he's also doing all
these things that are gonna affect this
it's not like we're talking about
freedom of speech to you know say what
you want to say on Fox we're talking
about someone who could become the
president and you're speaking with your
dollars that you want this in office and
I said Howard how could i with in good
faith say this thing on Twitter about
not sending people and about and really
almost losing a friendship with Sam and
then go behind anonymously and take the
money I just felt like I couldn't live
with myself no one would have ever known
but I would have known and it just
didn't make any sense to me so I said
yeah so I said to them to the to the
people that were vetting it I said you
know this is a really hard decision and
I thank them first for doing this and
that the thing was it was actually half
a million because they were going to
have someone else in their portfolio
come in as well I said it was can't take
the money
thank you for ya first for sharing it I
want to dive into one other situation
just to understand about resilience and
so there was a lot of attention a little
while ago when you announced the it's
about damn time fund yeah you announced
it as a thirty six million dollar fund
yes and then it didn't close yes and so
what I want to first ask is what when
you when you announced and I want to and
what I want to really understand is how
you have gone through that process from
a resilience perspective but first just
so that people understand the facts when
you made the announcement was it legally
signed did they sign the
comments' well for the commitments or
did you make the announcement with a
verbal commitment what I what I
announced was and four months we had
been working on it yeah we first the
first thing we did because we were going
to be in a six episode podcast the
gimlet podcast where I was good at five
hundred thousand or so people were going
to be listening every week the first
thing our lawyer said was this fun that
you're doing quietly that before it was
announced has to be a general
solicitation fund because you're priming
the pump you're going to be accused of
that so we were like really immerse okay
so we signed it up as a general
solicitation which means you can talk
about it press usually you can't talk
about fundraising while it's happening
that's the first thing we did so our
general solicitation so I could talk
about it here I can talk about it
anywhere the second thing that happened
was we I was speaking at an event May
2018 and on that panel I announced that
we were raising a 36 million dollar fund
that was going to be deployed a million
dollars at a time we had we had an
anchor and we had some commitments it
was not fully raised like 80% of funds
and you know this as a fund manager most
funds don't get raised overnight because
we had the general solicitation I was
able to talk about it sooner than most
people would I did it because I wanted
people to hear about it I wanted people
to want to invest in it so I made the
announcement we were doing that in the
room I think people understood what I
was saying cuz I said we're raising it
the first when I got off stage my phone
blew up it was a different world when I
got off stage the first people to write
the story about it were recode Peter
Kafka he wrote him a backstage has 36
million dollars - I immediately wrote to
him and I said it's we're raising it
he immediately retracted and said
backstage is seeking 36 million dollars
some people took that headline and said
it correctly and some people did it I
went on Twitter and I said we're raising
it I had a little picture of cardi B I
said we're raising it the same day all
of that any time anybody asked me I said
we're raising it because I wanted people
to invest in it we already had you know
20% of it committed throughout the
throughout the year a lot of things
happen really
good things happen but one of the bad
things that happened was the anchor that
we had where it so it's a little bit
sensitive because that anchor was a
black person themselves and I really
wanted them to be the anchor they backed
up can you walk us through that so how
did you feel when you how did you find
that out and how did they backed out
yeah and how did you feel at that moment
then how did you I mind you know what
the it was it was going to be their
first investment out of a very large
fund and they had a lot of experience in
the past and they were finding out that
they were not going to be able to close
their first clothes so to me I was like
and this has happened many times where I
thought as bad as this sucks this is the
least of their worries right now because
they have to now and I thought I really
thought at least it's not me I don't
have to worry about this amount this
crazy amount and I thought you know I
just just spent the last three four
years raising brick-by-brick I'll do the
same thing here so our plan was we had
two companies that were lined up in our
diligence we were going to invest in
those two companies this is a fund
that's going to be deployed over three
four five years a little bit at a time
as long as we do it as long as we do it
in some way we can do it so I wasn't I
wasn't concerned that's why I didn't
panic or say anything I was disappointed
and it felt like I had taken two steps
forward to take ten steps back but this
happens all the time to us all the time
we have billionaires who pull out the
last minute all the time who go on
Twitter or get their Forbes article and
then and then take from us so I I have
I've been used as an example in a new
and the adaptability quotient so there's
EQ IQ and aq now I am used as the
baseline example of aq because my
adaptability so the level is so high
because we've had so advanced so many
disappointments so it was it was
devastating but it wasn't the first time
wasn't the first time and you knew that
you had the long term vision 100 per
side look at things in decades I don't
look at them in quarters yeah right so
that's the key so it was just one foot
in front of the other
that's a great and I should say that a
few weeks ago I led a three million
dollar rate round from mommy I brought
in Mark Cuban for another million and I
brought in several Serena Williams to
join the round as well so we're doing
okay
awesome well with that I want to open it
up to the crowd so you can everybody
calm down
you can play teacher Arlington you get
to call whoever you want how do we plan
to work with the portfolio companies on
our new it's about damn time fund like
as compared to what we do now because
what we do what we do now is we have a
hundred and total about 130 companies
across these different funds
we're very hands on and a lot of them I
would say 20 to 30 percent we talk to on
a monthly basis it's probably ten
percent that we might as well be
cofounders and then the rest we just
have like this scalable way of talking
to them so they can come to us if they
need one one thing here there we don't
take any credit of course for building
their companies they're building them
but it's very much a tribe and a
community we try to get them together
either virtually or in person as often
as possible because that's when the real
magic happens and then I think what
we're best at is follow on finding
follow-on funding for companies and also
just being being there for them a lot of
times where their smallest check in
their first call and so with the new
fund the thing that will be different is
that we will invest like right now it's
about an average of 2% that we invest in
we'll probably invest in the point to
bright 2.2% like we'll invest in a lot
fewer companies because it's going to be
a larger check for us and then over in
the neck no two years from then then
we'll raise the bigger fun and we'll do
this and that but I think I think you
know if we're able to invest in three to
four of these companies per year
that our this million dollars at a time
they're more than likely going to get an
extra bit of my time which is which is
right now pretty difficult to do
yes I'm just going like it kind of yes
I'm just waiting for the type of
companies you're looking for are you
looking for companies that's going to
make everybody billionaires or do you
just me yeah do we look at companies
that are only about done it right now
you know right now um do we look for
companies are only about the bottom line
and they have to be like outside
unicorns or do we look at social impact
and it's a combination so I personally
will look at any of it you know the
first few funds that we have have a have
a limited partner agreement which is our
agreement with our investors it's very
specific and it's more traditional it's
like we're looking for companies that
can scale at a certain place and we're
trying to just as fund managers bring
them back three plus X you know I've
heard 10x before which means that
because so many companies will will die
out the winners have to be big big
winners financially I think they can be
both though there are a lot of companies
some of the companies that are doing the
best in our portfolio are social impact
companies and so I'm just kind of
bullish there anyway so I guess the best
way to answer it is to say that if I
were to start a fund from scratch from
my own capital I would be looking I
would be looking for companies that yes
could become unicorns it's all good and
also companies that would catalyze
others in a different way and kind of
measure it in different ways for sure
yes
what are the top three technologies so
just like the industries like yeah so
the I mean they're the verticals so
we're we're agnostic fund and an
agnostic fund so we see everything but
what what is really kind of coming to
the fore right now it's like health tech
specifically FEM tech but like a lot of
deep tech you know in the health space
fin tech and then consumer direct to
consumer yes yeah the next two or three
years in the valley I don't think about
anything when it comes to trends or what
other people are going to do I have no
idea what they're gonna do I know what I
like and what I like is things that have
to do it with renewable energy and with
health and then anything that's like
really like what's something that's
really been interesting recently is like
how do we how do we handle what's coming
with drones and managing them and how do
we handle what's coming with autonomous
vehicles and managing them like the
infrastructure for those types of things
not just the things themselves it's just
interesting to me personally and the
good thing is that we have many people
on the team who can write checks and
they have their each of their individual
preferences someone further back yes you
talked about the the early days when you
were getting rejected a lot how you
persevered and got through that yeah I
did a lot of crying yes I can thank you
can I talk about the early days how I
persevered through the hard parts the
hard times I cried a lot
fetal position
I cried a lot and I also did a lot of it
was it was very lonely not to make you
sad for me but it just was it was there
were weren't a lot of people who
understood from any world I was in right
they didn't understand what I was doing
so I would um I had I had that
whiteboard so that the the old place in
the new place I had the words keep going
written in red with an exclamation point
I would like look up at it and I would
say you know you you're a clever a few
days ago you told me that a month ago
I'm gonna do it so I would just tell
myself to keep going I would I would you
know let myself feel the pain of it and
not be ashamed right I would let myself
go through that because it's like the
wave of it is probably important but
then I would think about what if what if
this works what if that person that you
know is just an amazing founder who is
just inexplicably being overlooked gets
a chance at this and does well and you
had some small part in that you have to
go keep going and I would just kind of
talk myself out of despair that was a
lot of it and then music music helped me
a lot it's weird I never say this but I
should say this so when I would be
feeling down and I need to kind of get
myself psyched to go to have like this
power meeting I would listen to walk the
moons I'm shut up and dance I don't know
why but it just got me height of course
I listen to like cardi B back didn't
think a little bit and I listened to a
little Kim and Rihanna and Beyonce I did
all that but that one song was like my
good luck song so there was a question
right here yes in the back so as the
black women led companies in the US only
or other countries its global the fund
yeah sorry the fund are we looking only
in the US or globally one of our
accelerators is in London and so we've
already started there so we have a lot
of British and African despoja spora
companies led companies and then
[Music]
I thought you're going to ask for what I
get asked a lot which by black men which
is like have you forgotten about us and
the majority the most the biggest group
in our current portfolio is black men
just as a an aside for anyone who's
questioning them yes right what's my
advice we get in front of me as a
founder since I get inundated with
investments my true advice and a lot of
times I say this to people in person and
they kind of like you see them sort of
sink back and they're just like oh
you're blowing me off this is my true
advice especially not necessarily today
because I didn't come here with anybody
but usually I'm here I'm in person with
you with someone on my team and if I'm
seeing a thousand pitches a year there
may be seeing a hundred I would just
don't even just bypass me just go to
them because a lot of people on our team
can write checks now you can do that
virtually - I don't think the answer is
to find me there are Christie pizzas my
investment partner you can reach her at
her first name at backstage capital
Britney Davis is our head of dill flow
you can reach her at Britney at
backstage capital we have Anastasia we
have Chacho we have many venture
partners like a Lolita Adele all over
the country go to our website look up
our team and look at something like find
someone on there that you think oh I
they went to this school maybe I can
talk to them about that or they like to
have this hobby I can talk to them about
that or maybe I could just ask them what
it's like to be on the road with Arlen
because I can see their honor I would
just be hacked
if it were me that's what I would be
doing I wouldn't be going to the person
who's like just I get pitched so often
that honestly when I like especially
right now I woke up at 3:45 this morning
somebody tried to pitch me earlier today
I honestly just I put it I couldn't tell
you what they said I couldn't tell you
because I was just like oh but I say
like email me you know I'm at arlen
effort at backstage capital com a lot of
our founders it took them like a year or
six months to get an investment from us
and it's not company you'd tell you
not to do don't send a message and then
a month later send like I'm only gonna
ask you one more time we get that
passive-aggressive stuff and I'm like oh
let me get my checkbook I'm so sorry
no like being real like think about it
like let's be cool I'm not gonna reach
everybody but and also I would say
listen to the podcast your first million
because I talk a lot about these hacks
and that and you learn a lot about me
the last thing I'll say is if you're on
Twitter don't just look at what people
tweet go to their page and see what they
like and it doesn't always mean they
agree with the things they're liking but
it tells you kind of what they are doing
with their free time or with their time
and it's actually you can learn a lot I
learned a lot about our investors that
way and found investors that way so with
that I have to draw this part of ETL to
a close please Joey thank you thanking
Harlan Hamilton